principale divergence entre le président
du département des yvelines et le
gouvernement l'avenir de la métropole du
grand paris pierre bédier a répété lors
d'un rendez-vous récemment avec emmanuel
macron qu'il souhaitait une métropole
élargie à la région sur un sujet si
complexe il ne crois pas d'ailleurs le
président de la république capable de
faire son choix rapidement
nous avons des enjeux internationaux à
travers le break sites à travers les
jeux olympiques qui sont absolument
considérables et donc il faut réformer
cette région parisienne avec beaucoup de
prudence
il faut avancer d'une main tremblante et
il me semble qu'il faut prendre du temps
non sans lien les annonces sur le grand
paris express honte un scandale d'état
pour pierre bédier
selon lui le gouvernement ne donnerait
pas toutes les informations sur les
dates de livraison et soit une
accélération du calendrier de la ligne
18 pour soutenir le développement du
plateau de saclay dans ce cas-là
suspendons la croissance du plateau de
saclay ou alors et c'est ce que nous
demandons inversion des priorités
d'autres lignes du grand paris express
nous paraissent moins prioritaires et
faisons d'abord cette ligne de saclay
puisqu'il paraît que c'est à saclay que
se prépare l'avenir de la france enfin
la situation des républicains dans les
yvelines le président du département a
reconnu les difficultés de son parti
localement après les échecs aux
élections législatives et le presque
départ depuis du secrétaire
départemental david douillet pour tenter
de relancer la droite yvelinoise il
proposera une présidence collégiale dans
les prochains mois j'aimerais bien
pouvoir former en quelque sorte ces
personnes en formant un ticket pour
faire que notre fédération repartent de
l'avant
jusqu en octobre et l'élection d'une
nouvelle équipe dirigeante et l'air dans
les yvelines c'est sophie primas
sénatrice qui assumera l'intérim à la
tête du parti